>> Tucker: THE POLLS HAVE CLOSED
IN THE SPECIAL ELECTION IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE'RE WAITING TO SEE WHO WON.
THE RESULTS ARE COMING IN NOW.
HILLARY CLINTON THOUSANDS OF
MILES AWAY IN INDIA.
SHE FIGURES IT'S SAFE TO SAY
WHAT SHE REALLY THINKS ABOUT
YOU.
WATCH.
>> HIS WHOLE CAMPAIGN MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN IS LOOKING
BACKWARDS.
YOU DIDN'T LIKE BLACK PEOPLE
GETTING RIGHTS.
YOU DON'T WANT WOMEN GETTING
JOBS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO SEE THE INDIAN
AMERICAN SUCCEEDING.
WHATEVER YOUR PROBLEM IS, I'M
GOING TO SOLVE IT.
WE DON'T DO WELL WITH MARRIED
WHITE WOMEN.
AND PART OF THAT IS AN
IDENTIFICATION WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND A SORT OF
ONGOING PRESSURE TO VOTE THE WAY
THAT YOUR HUSBAND, YOUR BOSS,
YOUR SON, WHOEVER, BELIEVES YOU
SHOULD.
>> Tucker: NOTICE WHO HILLARY
CLINTON DID NOT BLAME FOR HER
LOSS.
HERSELF.
OR HER IDEAS OR ANYTHING SHE'S
EVER SAID OR DONE.
BUT IT IS A MISTAKE TO MAKE THIS
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE'S A FIGURE OF THE PAST.
HER IDEAS ARE VERY MUCH A
FEATURE OF THE PRESENT.
THE CLIP YOU JUST HEARD
PRECISELY SUMS UP THE VIEW OF
THE LEFT IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
A BIGOTED MIDDLE CLASS IS
HOLDING BACK PROGRESS.
THEY BELIEF THAT.
SO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, VOTERS
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE COUNTRY
DON'T HAVE LEGITIMATE VIEWS OR
ASPIRATIONS.
THEY ONLY HAVE UGLY GUT
REACTIONS.
THEY'RE RACIST AND WHITE PEOPLE.
WHITE WOMEN, HILLARY CLINTON
SAYS, CAN'T THINK FOR
THEMSELVES.
THEY'RE ATTACHED TO THE STUBBORN
LITTLE CELLS OF INDEPENDENCE
CALLED FAMILIES.
NOTHING STANDS IN THE WAY OF
POWER LIKE FAMILIES SO THEY MUST
BE SMASHED.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE.
HILLARY MAY BE WASHED UP BUT SHE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE GOALS ARE.
AND JULIE IS HERE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I DON'T WANT TO BEAT
UP ON HILLARY.
>> YOU DON'T?
I THOUGHT THAT'S WHY YOU BROUGHT
ME ON.
>> Tucker: I'M SINCERE.
SHE LOST.
I FEEL SORRY FOR THE LOSER.
I THINK SHE'S BECOME LESS
POPULAR AMONG DEMOCRATS AND
HUMILIATING HERSELF.
I DON'T WANT TO POUND ON HER.
I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
IDEAS.
I'M STRUCK.
SHE'S THE PERFECT EMBODIMENT OF
AN ATTITUDE THAT PERVADES THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE LOST AND IT'S YOUR FAULT.
YOU'RE BIGOTS AND YOU'RE
STANDING IN THE WAY OF PROGRESS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
ATTITUDE?
IT'S EVERYWHERE.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A FAIR
ATTITUDE.
ONE VALID POINT THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE MAKE WHEN TALKING ABOUT A
LOT OF THE STATEMENTS THAT
HILLARY CLINTON MAKES IS SHE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY TALK ABOUT
THE TACTICAL ERRORS THAT HER
TEAM MADE AS FAR AS CAMPAIGNING
AND APPEALING TO THE MIDDLE OF
THE COUNTRY.
SO WHILE I CERTAINLY AM
PERSONALLY AGAINST THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS CURRENTLY
IN OFFICE AND A LOT OF THE
THINGS THEY STAND FOR, I THINK
THAT THE DEMOCRATS ALSO NEED TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE ERRORS THAT THEY
MADE IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
>> Tucker: I HEAR THAT A LOT.
A LOT OF TOP PEOPLE IN THE
HILLARY CAMPAIGN ARE SMARTER
THAN I AM.
THEY HAD A BILLION DOLLARS.
THERE WASN'T A LOT OF TACTICAL
THINKING THAT THEY WERE NOT
AWARE OF.
THEY DID THE TACTICS RIGHT.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY DID.
I'M NOT TO ARGUE ABOUT THE
PROBLEMS OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> Tucker: COULD THE PROBLEM
HAVE BEEN THAT THEY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THE MIDDLE CLASS
OF THE COUNTRY WAS DYING IN
ABSOLUTE TERMS AND FELT HATED
AND DISMISSED BY THEM?
THAT MAYBE WAS THE PROBLEM.
DON'T YOU THINK?
>> WHEN I TALK ABOUT A TACTICAL
ISSUE, NOT APPEALING TO THE
MIDDLE PART OF THE COUNTRY, NOT
DELIVERING THE ECONOMIC MESSAGES
THAT WOULD RESONATE WITH THOSE
PEOPLE, YEAH, THAT WAS A
TACTICAL ERROR.
YEAH.
>> Tucker: IT'S A DEEP ERROR.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HILLARY'S
LINE -- AGAIN, I'M NOT BEATING
UP ON HER.
BUT THIS GETS TO A CORE
CONTRADICTION IN MODERN
FEMINISM.
WHITE WOMEN THAT SHE SAID WITH
DISDAIN VOTED FOR TRUMP BECAUSE
THEY WERE PRESSURED BY THEIR
HUSBANDS AND SONS.
SHE THINKS THAT WOMEN ARE SO
WEAK-MINDED THAT THEIR BOSSED
AROUND BY THEIR SONS IN THE
VOTING BOOTH?
DOESN'T THAT TELL YOU A LOT?
ISN'T THAT REVEALING?
>> AS MUCH AS I HATE THAT SOUND
BITE, IT MAKES IT SOUND AS
THOUGH WOMEN ARE INCAPABLE OF
MAKING THEIR OWN DECISIONS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE VOTING BOOTH.
AS MUCH AS I WISH THIS WEREN'T
TRUE, THERE'S DATA TO BACK THAT
UP.
THERE'S A STUDY BY OREGON STATE
UNIVERSITY THAT SAID WOMEN,
WHITE WOMEN, ARE UNDULY
PRESSURED BY THEIR PARTNERS WHEN
IT COMES TO MAKING POLITICAL
DECISIONS AND GENERALLY THAT
WOMEN HAPPEN TO -- BASICALLY
WHEN, WHEN THEY'RE UNMARRIED,
THEY TEND TO VOTE WITH THE GOOD
OF THEIR GENDER IN MIND.
WHEREAS ONCE THEY'RE MARRIED,
THEY ARE MORE LIKELY TO VOTE IN
THEIR HUSBAND'S BEST ECONOMIC
INTERESTS.
THIS IS LARGELY BECAUSE WOMEN
HOLD LESS MONEY AND EARN LESS
MONEY AND HOLD LESS POWER IN
THIS COUNTRY AND THERE'S
EVIDENCE TO BACK UP THE FACT
THAT WOMEN WHEN MARRIED AND
SPECIFICALLY WHITE WOMEN TEND TO
VOTE WITH THEIR HUSBAND'S
ECONOMIC INTERESTS IN MIND AND
THAT IS PERCEIVED TO BE FOR
WHITE WOMEN AT LEAST VOTING
REPUBLICAN.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU HAVE A
GROUP OF PEOPLE, MARRIED WHITE
PEOPLE AND YOU SPENT LIKE A HUGE
AMOUNT OF TIME ATTACKING THEM ON
THE BASIS OF THEIR RACE AND
THEIR MARITAL STATUS AS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND --
>> Tucker: YES.
IT'S NOT THEIR CONSTITUENCY.
THE POLICIES ARE AIMED AT THE
UNMARRIED PEOPLE.
>> THINK THAT'S VASTLY UNTRUE.
>> Tucker: LAST WEEK CHUCK
SCHUMER SAD HE WASN'T GOING TO
SUPPORT A FEDERAL JUDICIAL
NOMINEE BECAUSE HE WAS WHITE.
I WONDER, IS THAT -- WHAT DO YOU
THINK THE NET EFFECT OF THAT IS?
IS THAT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY,
FOR POLITICIANS TO SAY THAT KIND
OF THING OUT LOUD?
>> YOU'RE MISCHARACTERIZING THE
FACT THAT DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
TRYING TO APPEAL TO MARRIED
PEOPLE.
I THINK THEY'RE TRYING TO APPEAL
TO AN IDEOLOGY ADOPTED BY
MARRIED AND UNMARRIED PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I LIKE MARRIED WOMEN.
I THINK I HAVE A HIGHER OPINION
OF WOMEN THAN YOU DO AND I'M NOT
A FEMINIST.
I THINK THEY VOTE THE WAY THEY
WANT TO VOTE.
ONES I KNOW DO.
>> I THINK THAT THAT IS BY AND
LARGE TRUE.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT SHE SAID
OVERSIMPLIFIED IT IN THAT
PARTICULAR INSTANCE.